mike libecki this guy has completely
changed my life I met Mike in 2012 we
did an expedition to Greenland
this is a picture of Mike after a trip
we did when we went to china kyrgyzstan
border did a big rock climb and we lived
you know when you live out for a month
out in the backcountry you start to
stink all your stuff smells right you
can't wait for the hotel you can't wait
to just pack all that stuff up and put
it away and be like I will deal with you
when I get home like I need like two
days of rest I want to get clean Mike
he's so driven so I we get to our first
hotel and we're all like so excited I go
just stuff ignored and I remember taking
a shower and I walk over into Mike's
room when he's sharing a room with this
other guy Ethan and I come in their room
and it smells like Basecamp but Michael
what's going on I'm either that all of
his wet stuffs is out drying he's
already taking inventory and everything
you have he's so motivated it's almost
like he's leaving for another expedition
like right after this which he probably
was he's done like 60 expeditions he's
amazing and I look over and my friend
Ethan he's doing that thing where you
got your shirt over your nose but he's
like reading could I come in he's like
hey wasn't even like he said anything
like those into sake was just like hit
accept that it is f1 but mike is that
guy is so motivated so I did this trip
with him in Greenland and after the trip
he said to me he's like man I'm planning
on going to Antarctica this you know in
November and I think national
Geographics on board he's like do you
want to come you could you can be the
filmmaker I'm talking to Cory Richards
he's going to be the photographer and
Freddie Wilkinson he's going to be my
climbing partner so I knew all these
guys right and I was like that sounds
like an incredible trip it's like okay
well I'm planning on it being two months
you're going to need to take two months
off if it happens and I said I'll make
if this comes through like I'll make it
work so sure enough National Geographic
they're into this story and off we went
down to Antarctica for one of the
coolest adventures of my life an
incredible expedition getting to
Antarctica is not simple it's not like
you just call up like United and you
just like fly down it's like a series of
slice and so we're in South Africa here
this plane here this is like an old
military plane
run by this group called all see it's a
Russian outfit and basically we show up
you board this flight and you get on and
it's a six-hour flight from the tip of
South Africa to Antarctica and it's a
crazy flight it's not like you get on
and there's like flight attendants it
says this is a bunch of like scientists
and like military people that work on
this base and the porta-potties are like
bolted down to the bats of toilet
situation and then your gear you think
this is like cargo nets I'm like what
about if there's turbulence I don't I
don't think they care can just get
bucked around a Mexican so anyway we get
on the flight we're like this is kind of
crazy well the flight only has enough
gas to make it across the ocean right
when you get to the halfway point it's
called the point in our return so when
they go they really make sure there's a
good weather window right so we waited
in Cape Town for it was a week or more
waiting for that weather window to
happen and then when it happened when we
got it boom you go down and you land in
this like completely new place right
it's summer in South Africa in November
and then you arrive down here where it's
you know minus 20 like right off the
plane you get dressed like an hour
before you oh they said this send up
this little signal I could put your
clothes on and you just like fully get
dressed and then when you get off you
start hauling your bags and there's guys
waiting there were sleds
they take you to your little home these
little conics containers so day one
really nice weather window we got in Bay
2 we wake up and it's crazy outside it's
like the winds picked up freezing cold
this lasted for about five days right
and they're just the people there
they're used to it they're just like
plow and stuff keeping the flight paths
clean
we're just festering in our rooms for
like this is awful just kind of
purgatory waiting and what you do every
day is you go in you check the weather
as the weather changed you know it
hasn't what you ask anyway
so on the fifth day this guy here is
like the Russian meteorologist he's kind
of explaining like hey looks like you
guys are going to have a window you can
have like a 10 hour window it's going to
be really short so we took all the gear
it's like 1,800 pounds of gear like
duffel bags everything else load it in
the plane and the pilot explained to us
like look I can get you in but you guys
got to get your gear real quick
I got to get back if so the thing goes
like 200 miles and there's Mike
perpetually excited he's like
unflappable this guy I've seen him break
his hand he's like ah you know I'm not
I'm not kidding and he's the only guy
that got frostbite on the trip then to
use no problem until anyway you land you
unpacked and then watching the plane go
away that's a very surreal feeling right
that is the last bit of heat and comfort
and and I forget we were there fifty
days or some crazy right and you and you
really it's things and quick you know as
you're pulling all the equipment off
you're just like man this it's on places
is happening and and then the first
thing you do is there's no time to waste
because we know how quickly the weather
changes down there first thing you do is
we built base camp and what we did was
we're out in the middle of the ice cap
here so we just like cut out ice blocks
and this is all under Mike's guidance
he'd been to Antarctica six times even
in a solo trip which to this day I don't
know how he did it and we you know you
built this perimeter and this is really
more for wind and we set up base camp
and life was pretty good we were psyched
I remember waking up the next morning
and it was already the walls already
bent and like collapsing and Freddie's
out there like just shoveling and doing
maintenance and I'm like wow
this is going to be a full-time job just
keeping this thing together but the plan
was to not stay here the plan was we
were going to do a big circumnavigation
around the entire mountain range I'm
going to look for the perfect climbing
line and do a little exploration so what
we did is we Pat you note on day three
because we knew the weather was like
okay we packed up our sleds and about 90
pounds each with tents and food and the
plan was the kite ski so this is mike
libecki here attempting to kite ski
it was crazy watching him take off it
was it was the fifth element at a
slingshot they're like and so we knew
that wasn't going to work so we and I
was relieved because I don't even know
how to ski I screw up snowboarding I go
snowboarding and so anyway day one we
just we it was probably 10 hours of this
and we show up at the end at the end of
the day we're like okay we have to set
up base camp while the winds were
hideously howling and we found this
little tiny Boulder here and that was
the only little shelter we had to kind
of to get behind it's probably like 1:00
in the morning at this point you know
the sun's always up in the summertime
down there it's like Midnight Sun and so
I remember this day being the worst day
of the whole trip and thank God it was
like days 3 or 4 but I just like I had
no frame of reference I'm like this is
this is going to be hard I don't know
what I'm going to do here because just
setting this camp up was awfully weak I
remember Cory and I getting in our tent
and you're soaking wet from all because
you're you're overheating because you're
working and then the snows is going all
down you and you just wet you know and
I'm like I can't do 45 days man that
bike and Freddy are in there just like
laughing and guys fun right and I'm like
yeah super fun and so for five days we
circumnavigated this mountain range and
it was a surreal experience I've never
done anything like it you know it was
either snow and skis or on the right
here there was times where it would be
just miles and miles of just blue
sapphire blue ice and it was never just
flat it was it was very
three-dimensional and you'd put crampons
on and you would just walk and there
were times where we would be staggered
by like maybe even a mile apart so you
would be pretty alone at one point I
left a tripod I stopped and I shot some
pictures or video and as the you know we
stopped at our next little rough spot
like two miles up and I went to grab my
tripod and I left it and I had to go
back Cory waited for me and Mike and
Freddy were like we need to find a base
camp so I went back and I remembered
during that little two-mile walk back it
was it was like a beautiful scary
feeling you know it was like you don't
want anything bad to happen because
that would be terrible you're in a bad
situation to be get injured but it was
also surreal and kind of interesting to
be like wow this is the farthest away
I've ever been from people in my entire
life and probably ever will be and that
you can experience that in Antarctica so
the plan is you know you set up these
little satellite camps and we would run
into the mountains and we would use
binoculars trying to find the perfect
climb and on the final day we actually
did get to this kite ski and again I've
never skied before I wish I had this on
film
I remember everyone's like we're at our
wits end at this point it's day five
we're all tired we're just pining to get
back to base camp we're tired and so
Mike's helping me set my kite up right
and you know as I've never skied I can
cross-country ski pretty good at this
point and I understand edging just from
you know using my ideas from
snowboarding but it's different
whiskey's and so Mike's helping me out
and he's got my kite he's going to
launch it for me right let it get filled
with wind and he says to me the last
thing you so he's like remember keeps a
french fries whatever you ski you know
what that means if you've done it
basically means to slow down pizza to go
fast french fries right I'm like oh man
but so off I go when they probably got
about I would say a mile maybe a little
more and I'm gripped right but I'm
making it work it is totally like flight
or fight or flight and he looked nervous
letting me go because you could break
your leg man I got 90 pounds of stuff
like tents and crampons and stuff and it
can't you know you've got these poles so
it's sort of separated from you but it's
not great and everyone's left right
we've got walkie-talkies but we're all
very spread out at this point and so I
go taking off and and these guys all had
like a little harness so they could kind
of clip their handle onto so you know
it's good you don't having to grip onto
this thing and use all your strength you
just have to kind of navigate it I
didn't have a harness and and I'm just
holding it right and so about a mile
into the thing and you're screaming fast
I'm like I cannot hold this thing
anymore you know I'm pumped out of my
mind and Mike said okay when you want to
drop the kite you move the bar this way
it'll move the strings the window fall
the kite will fall down so I'm just like
trying to Pizza french fries my crazy
thinking of like whole
the thing and the kite won't fall right
I'm just like this is terrible so
finally I get the point where I can't
hold it anymore
nice let me go where's like I watch to
just sail away and I'm like I have to go
get it man
so bad and I fell to my knees and I did
the only thing I could do was I knew I
had to like get this rage out so it's
all my knees very tired but I remember I
just like pounded mostly like a child I
just like powder my system to snow and
like scream some curse word and then I
was like okay that's all you can't man
you got to go get it so I put my skins
on which is a total process right and I
and then when I try to get out well the
worst part is is I'd get like ten feet
from the kite and the way is it hit the
ground out in the wind would just be
like you know like oh man if I get it
with like your pole and it was just it
did that for like a mile right and I
almost left it but I just was like this
is my trash I need to back it up so I
got it and I stuffed it into my thing I
was like I'll never use this again I
didn't like fold it up nicely at all
anyway that I need to move on okay so we
get back to base camp right and this is
what we came back to five days was
enough to just utterly ravage our camp
right and poor Freddy
he was the writer so the writer should
always have the worst experience so have
like maybe he needs something to talk
about so his tent was totally destroyed
right but we knew like we cannot stay
here but on our trip we we found out
where we wanted to climb right reflected
in Mike's Colossus here the tower on the
right that was the line so that was good
we had accomplished something but we
knew we have to move all this gear and
we cannot stay out in this ice cap so we
moved into the callus field over here
the towers just slightly out of frame on
the left but all 1,800 pounds of gear
had to go to took two days right of just
like load after load you'd ski it in and
then you'd have to like to hike it up
but we found this really great spot kind
of mostly out of the wind and it was
close enough to the tower and we nestled
in and it was
great there was the wind was a lot less
the snow was the real problem because
the wind just pushes snow on you all the
time when we were out of that but the
one thing we we know the only bet the
only non benefit of the snow is we had
to find little snow patches of snow that
had collected and that's where we would
have to like you know fill up big duffle
bags and that's for how we drink our
water so this little white stuff you're
seeing and the snow there that's like
bird poop that's like a thousand years
old man because there's birds that are
down there but nothing decomposes right
so you dig down like three feet and is
everything was full of white stuff then
we realize that pretty quick and it's
crazy on expeditions how you just stop
caring about certain things the
cleanliness of your bowl you know
everything this becomes like one like
amalgam of spice where there's like
coffee and my curry just like eating
you're like mmm I guess he just stopped
caring in the bird poop was just all
part of the amalgam right and so anyway
the objective was we had the real
objective was to climb is 2200 foot you
know spire beautiful piece of rock the
little guy on the corner down there
that's Cory we just now start moving in
our equipment to get to the base of the
climb and then start it and so over the
next like 40 days Mike and Freddie just
threw themselves at this tower inching
their way up and every now and then
you'd get a storm that would blow in and
it would last for one to five days and
you just kind of bunker down and hang
out and then these guys would get right
back on the wall and circle and up again
and slowly they inch their way closer
and closer to the top until we're
completely victorious and it was an
incredible adventure and I'll show you
the three minute short film you can also
watch it online but this is a stream in
a film that was made from it as well as
the television show
this is one of the most challenging
environments for a climber you can visit
anywhere on planet Earth big part of the
game is approaching these unclimbed
unexplored mountains and and looking for
the coolest way to get to the top that
for us as climbers is the path we spent
a week ski touring around looking you
know with binoculars at every mountain
within striking distance of us and this
is without a doubt the proudest line we
found the environment is so hostile you
die up here in a matter of hours without
the right gear and the right expertise
like the SWAT team special weapons and
tactics this is an aid climbing or free
climbing or speed climbing this is just
like whatever it takes
it'll be spicy for sure every day we
wake up and
we don't know what we're going to be
able to do safely you definitely have to
work for everything in Antarctica
nothing is a given you have to earn it
unpredictability it's about you know the
unknown
hundreds of mountains that are unclimbed
it's like being an astronaut going up
there going into outer space you need to
have a survival suit on need to be
prepared for everything as a
counterbalance to that extreme
consequence and severity is just these
moments of surreal otherworldly beauty
[Music]
thank you I'm glad you enjoyed it you
know it was it's pretty incredible
looking back at that magazine the
National Geographic story storming the
tower all those years ago you know and
then flashing forward to 2012 and really
going and doing my own version of
storming the tower having an adventure
for people going out you know for close
friends and and and in two months having
our own sort of trials and tribulations
and Bill Hatcher is the photographer
that shot the story and I've since
become friends with Bill and it's it's
so fun exchanging stories and and
catching up and talking about the
different adventures and things we've
been on and it's really National
Geographic that inspired me down this
entire road to this like very platform
I'm standing on today and that's so rare
I I didn't even realize it until earlier
in the week when I pulled this photo to
talk about it as I was putting it into
the presentation this sort of full
circle situation that I'd kind of found
myself and it was it's just it's really
it's really quite cool so this is us at
the end successful all like barely worse
for wear after such a fun adventure oh I
try to put in my villa Becky bonus
material okay so the very odd about
those okay so two years ago Mike calls
me up then he says he's got another
tower project in mind for
but this time it's very different it's
in the it's in the small country called
a POW it's down in like the South
Pacific right I'd never heard of it
before and he sent me some photos and
I'm like wow this is crazy and so I'm
like oh man he calls me and my friend
Andy man and our friend Angie pain and
she's like this is the team of four and
we're all in right and it was this
beautiful tower right here this is it
towers called put maka and Mike said
something I've never heard him say
before when we were on the phone talking
about planning and logistics you know
we're all excited and he said there'll
be moments on the trip where you wish
you didn't come guys like a Texas I've
never never heard him say something like
that of like what do you mean you know
anyway I quickly learned what he meant
you know this is like day ten where in
Antarctica you know it's cold but you
can put clothing on you can sort of like
figure out a way to kind of deal with
the cold and then slit your self down
here it's just mud and heat and wet you
know and and even if you're wet and high
you still it's so what you have to like
protect yourself from like bugs and
bushes and everything else and you just
it was a completely different suffer
fest something like I've never had this
level of supper fest in my life but it
was still so much fun so I'm going to
show you the film this is actually going
to be screening at hope I get the name
right it's the International
conservation Film Festival I think
that's right and in the next couple
weeks if you want to see the film it'll
be here in DC very soon real on May
apparently it's mayhem a ship here but
once like here we'll figure it out or
got going my sweet danke seen waves turn
way you never do what to say
[Music]
jungle mayhem ahead mystery completely
you know what mr. Ibrahim this is the
kind of moment of life where it's a good
this is what was holding me
[Music]
maybe the most miserable things fun
anger
[Music]
boom ah thank you so yes if you want to
see that that'll be here in two weeks at
that Film Festival I wanted to end
talking about two projects I recently
worked on and they're both climate
change based in 2015 I get a phone call
from National Geographic magazine asking
me if I would be interested in working
on a climate change story on America's
national parks and I the outdoors is my
life it means so much to me that the
beautiful place is in our national park
system here we're so lucky we have this
incredible parks and so I course I said
yes and I started you know National
Geographic they set you up for success
right there was scientists and
biologists and different contacts like
people I could talk to so you could kind
of figure out like what the story is and
you start learning things in this way
it's remarkable and so I'm going to just
run you through the different photos
right so this is in Glacier National
Park this is the Grinnell glacier right
you can see the three different parts of
it and in like twenty years ago this was
all connected and actually kind of like
covering most of the lake and thirty to
forty years ago it was actually kind of
running down the mountain the glaciers
in the park are receiving so quickly
that they say that by 2030 they'll be
gone all the glaciers in Glacier
National Park will be gone he then heat
indexes keeps going up right it's
getting warmer all the time this is in
Sequoia National Park these trees are
the oldest living trees in the world
they're also the tallest living trees
now they get an excess of 300 feet tall
and these big trees they drink as much
as 500 gallons of water a day
right they require a lot of water and
they're completely unique to the Sierra
Mountains right they're endemic to this
one little spot in California and if
you've ever seen them you know what I'm
talking about they are incredible but
you know with heat index on the rise and
drought they're already starting to see
a lot of signs of stress
these trees and there's a lot of
question marks as to whether or not
these they're national treasures
actually but you know what the future of
these trees is looking like things are
changing so quickly this is smoke from
this is in Glacier National Park and
this is smoke from fires some as far as
Washington State like all the smoke that
had kind of blown in and fire danger is
going up higher and higher every year
there's actually they're seeing fire in
the Arctic places like Far North Alaska
it's crazy you like places that have
never experienced virus before and it's
all based on like the drought and heat
factor this is an American alligator
this is down in the Everglades National
Park I really fell in love with the
Everglades it's such a special place and
the Everglades is down in the southern
tip of the state and it's surrounded by
water on all three sides and with ocean
sea rise the salinity levels of the
water are slowly changing you know as
the ocean Rises a little more it starts
pushing this is all freshwater in the
Everglades
and because the parks all the way down
in the South as the water keeps kind of
ocean kind of keeps rising the salinity
levels are changing
well American alligators that's not an
endangered species but the thing with
this this alligator is it's real refuge
is kind of down in the Everglades as is
a lot of the animals that are down there
especially the freshwater ones they're
slowly going to get pushed further north
and eventually out of the park and then
it's mostly just residential it's a
completely different place Florida once
you get out of these wild wetlands and
so there's a lot of animals that are
kind of there's a lot of question marks
this is in Joshua Tree National Park and
they're saying that by the year 2100
there be there may be no new sprouts
from Joshua trees I think in 30% of the
parks there hasn't been any sprout in
like two decades or something it's
already kind of happening and these are
crazy signs and when I got the
assignment I was told like a lot of what
you're shooting can look at it like it's
time capsule photography like you're
shooting things the way they are now but
they're changing really quickly and it
would be wild to think about Joshua Tree
National Park without Joshua trees
sequoia national park without sequoia
trees or glacier national park without
glaciers etc and the big question is
like what do you do and the I think the
big answer is you know we need good
legislation people that are making good
decisions that can make the big changes
and then for us it's basically making
small choices like using less water when
you can and carpooling with other people
when you can smaller decisions with
there's 7 billion people on the planet
and it's it's a really hard situation
but we kind of have to work collectively
together to hopefully make things you
know salvage things as we can the most
recent trip I did was down to Antarctica
they kind of talked briefly about the
beginning I went down with Paul Nicklin
and Cristina Madame IRA these are two of
my heroes I mean Paul's like a
photography legend he's I've loved his
work for so many years Cristina is she's
just got a heart of gold and she's gone
conservationist as is Paul and so Paul
led an expedition down there of a team
of amazing videographers VR and then
Cristina Paul and I worked in the photo
side for the magazine and what I saw it
on their both was completely
breathtaking and also quite revealing
so I'm going to walk you through kind of
the characters of Antarctica of what we
saw so we mostly concentrated on the
northern or sorry the southern part of
the peninsula right sorry the northern
part of the peninsula forgive me and we
went to all these different places and
we experienced we get to see like the
beauty of the place we got to see a lot
of the wildlife there's lots of wildlife
down there this is a classic example of
how pretty it is down there what you're
seeing here is like polished rocks where
ice used to be and it's kind of like
moved off now but it was beautiful big
glaciers floating by got lucky got some
really nice light there's big mountains
everywhere you go you're constantly
going through fjords and seeing these
beautiful mountain ranges that like
looks like the Tetons put your down and
you know in Antarctica you can see where
the glaciers have kind of receded I mean
they're losing ice very quickly down
there the animals you see down there you
see of course penguins is five different
types of penguins that live down there
and I think that I read there's about 11
million collectively that lived down
there okay you have all these great
seals this is a Weddell seal this is a
fur seal
and this is the like legendary like the
leopard seal right this is what Paul a
few familiar with Paul Nichol and in
2006 he did a leopard seal story that
was unbelievably iconic and I was such
an honor to get in the water with Paul
and have leopard seal interactions this
little like mouthing move right here
this is it looks like a threat display
but this is just to communicate with
like air bubbles and by opening their
mouths and seeing how you react and
they're also looking at the reflection
in your your dome of your camera so
there I think to them even it's sort of
this like new and weird kind of cool
thing but they were they were so
incredible to be in the water with and
then as you know you have the big
animals right you have the big whales
there's humpback whales and pilot whales
and Miki whales and all the rest okay so
that all these animals are connected to
one thing they're connected to krill
krill is like a little shrimp right and
all these animals their main source of
foods krill and the thing is is krill
krill eats bacteria and algae that grows
on sea ice
well sea ice is kind of receding we're
seeing it go away quite quickly and so
that's the krill food source and the
foods krill feeds everything well
fishing is kind of the big question mark
right now because there's fishing
companies from all over the world and
they're going in and they're sucking out
hundreds of thousands of tons of krill
every season and scientists are trying
to wrap their heads around like what is
the appropriate amount of krill that can
be taken out of the water and there you
know krill is used for like omega-3
supplements and some people eat it and
krill oil and different things like that
but we need to be responsible work we
need to kind of wrap our heads around
what is the appropriate amount of food
to take out because we're going to just
wipe out all these animals that are
completely codependent on this thing so
the story is based about fishing as much
as it is climate change you can see the
ice kind of receding here and again
krill need ice so all these honor other
animals need ice as well as do we but
you know we need to figure this out
a hundred years ago these are blue whale
bones right here you see them everywhere
they were really cool to see but they
weren't blue whales are just like we're
beach
you know and that kind of came up and
naturally died they were from fishing
about a hundred years ago the blue
whales the biggest animal that's ever
been on the planet Earth and it was
hunted to near-extinction about a
hundred years ago and we need to learn
you know from our mistakes in the past
one of the scientists on the boat said
that man has messed up every fishery in
the world in Antarctica is like our last
chance to do it correctly so we're
hoping for good legislation and good
decisions to kind of save this part of
the planet and I know that's an
interesting tone to end on after all
this adventure stuff I was talking about
but the this stuff is so important to me
and I'm hoping that we can you know do
something that's impactful with the
story that people can see this and
actually you know keep good eyes on
people that are making the decisions
that can keep these places in checks and
balances and that's everything I have
today thank you so much for listening
[Applause]
[Music]